[Applause]
[Music]
you wanna dance let's dance
are you concerned that Robert Miller
might look into your taxes let him look
at my taxes he can look at whatever it
wants as long as he doesn't look at my
taxes if there's an indictment filed
against you will you resign oh yeah sure
right after I tell Don Jr that I love
them what did you mean when you told the
New York Times you're actually not angry
at anybody I'm not angry at anybody I'm
furious with everybody and that's why
I'm renaming the tax bill the kill kill
kill bill didn't you want to call it the
cut cut cut act come on
is that a butter knife no it's a
reporter knife and that's why tonight's
theme is escape oh boy
that's gotta be what I think it is
so great so cool hey fella what a macho
guy gonna drive this bad boy I want to
drive this truck that boom
Wow I got it get in there yeah give us a
hog you're free now Donny go bye-bye
macho guys let's go
[Music]
later breaker there's a smokey on the
way he's a tough guy and he's finally
free yeah
[Music]
now
mr. president mr. president mr.
president oh yeah I'm the president
can you indict it let's roll